last six years what was it that you made
sure you did i think develop a process
because you can't really scale if you
don't have processes in place you have
to have good people around you
i think that's non-negotiable and i
think i was very much to begin with and
i feel like if i could re do the last
six years
i'd realized that like i'm i don't know
everything and what did you think you
did it was very like i'm right okay and
it's it's not about being right or wrong
it's about well what can you learn and
who can you have relationships around
you that are going to help you know grow
stuff taking on good advice and actually
implementing that because i've got an
amazing business partner and he always
said to me in the first couple of years
he's like if you just listen to
me what was it that like preventing you
from listening do you think just because
he had a business in the medical sector
yeah and my business being education i
was like yeah but you know that doesn't
apply for education
but yeah that's probably it because he
did really really well and so there
shouldn't have really been a reason
where i was like well he doesn't know
best yeah yeah but i think that being
able to just ensure that yes there's
going to be hard times like god those
couple first couple of years i cried a
lot like yeah that was my way of dealing
with it i'd go in a room and i'd have a
cry
and i think that's one of the things
that probably i don't necessarily see
that many people that own businesses
show their weaknesses and senses and
it's like it is hard but at the same
time what amazing things to achieve
through things that are just easy the
recruitment mentors podcast is proudly
sponsored by vincerie who are
weaponizing recruiters through tech and
the award-winning sauce breaker who are
transforming the way recruiters work